stars are paying tribute to comedy
legend Fred Willard you know in a career
that spanned more than 50 years he was a
part of some of the funniest movies and
TV shows in history he really was
Hollywood's go-to guy for laughs and if
you're a dog or a friend of a dog you
want to circle this night in your TV
Guide my part got particularly good word
of mouth mainly from me but you get the
joke done
and speaking of network word on the
street is they're looking for a new
anchor so Ron put network so there's
always fun to see a movie of Bennett the
work is over you didn't have to be there
at 7:00 in the morning and have the
makeup at night you can just sit back
and watch it
wallflowers it's time to blossom and
bloom
I think we've become actors to get out
of ourselves and do something different
Fred's daughter hope roped the sad news
saying quote my father passed away very
peacefully at the fantastic age of 86
years old he kept moving working and
making us happy until the very end thank
you oh come on Steve Carell called Fred
quote the funniest person that I've ever
worked with Roseanne Barr wrote a great
comic and a great person and Jimmy
Kimmel posted I am sad to say goodbye
don't you feel bad for all the students
that actually worked hard to study for
their SATs don't be so extra Jimmy hey
I'm making Bank I'm making money moves
like car TVs from this is spinal tap to
Everybody Loves Raymond and modern
family Fred was always in high demand
would you wear pants to breakfast for
crying out loud Fred's Hollywood legacy
will live on and so will his name look
who he proudly introduced us to back in
2005
this gentleman's with my agency and he
advises me at all
cartoon projects you know he's a junior
agent does my grandson Freddie
I want you to take a look at this
Freddie he's not so junior anymore by
the way we can enjoy Willard in one more
new series he appears in space force
with Steve Carell which hits Netflix on
the 29th
[Music]